former democratic congresswoman tulsi
gabbard is with us
um how do you feel i think it's in it
how do you feel about the ministry of
truth
uh this is the kind of thing that you
see in dictatorships this ministry of
truth this department of propaganda that
the biden administration has just stood
up and the reason why you see this in
dictatorships is because
they're afraid of us they're afraid of
the people they're afraid that we might
actually
think for ourselves and so now they've
created this this body
that will do two things number one we'll
use taxpayer dollars to uh work through
the mainstream media and flood the
airwaves with whatever their propaganda
narrative is that they're pushing at any
given time and try to drown out anyone
with alternate views and number two they
will silence dissenting voices uh
through intimidation
uh this is the i think the thing to
recognize with this just real quick is
that this isn't something new this is
something that they have already been
doing that's happening right now the the
only difference is they're formalizing
it making it official which if there's a
silver lining in this
it is they're revealing exactly who they
are and why they're doing it what
they're trying to accomplish and it
allows us the american people to stand
up and say hey you know what we're not
going to let you get away with this crap
we will take a stand we will reject it
and we will throw out of office those
who are continuing to push and propagate
this undemocratic anti-free speech
mission
i showed tapes of joe biden i'm going to
show you tapes of joe biden in 2008 and
12 and 16.
then i have a question on the other side
in our bilateral relationships with
nations with whom we deal and have
serious trade deficits we have to be
willing to put more cards on the table
now they got a new plan trust me it's
not going to cost you any more folks
follow your instincts on this one they
put one foot in front of the other
they keep going
that's the unbreakable spirit of the
people of america we hold these truths
to be self-evident
all men and women created by the go you
know the you know the thing i want to
thank
the
the
former general i keep calling in general
my
my
the guy who runs that outfit over there
i know you probably don't want this
question
you're you're a democratic party member
do you see a precipitous cognitive
decline in joe biden
i think it's distressing sean to see
that
i think that it's important
but as we look at what you've just
played out and what you're seeing is
that we not just focus on joe biden but
that we actually which is really
kind of a distraction away from to me
what is the more serious issue here
which is it's clear that joe biden's the
front man
and that there is the permanent
washington establishment behind the
curtains that are pulling the strings
you know i i don't believe that joe
biden came up with this department of
propaganda there are other people in
this permanent washington establishment
who are calling the shots who are making
the decisions that have a very real
impact negative impact on our democracy
and on our freedom and it's important
for us as the american people to see
very clearly what's happening not allow
them to distract us and stand up
strongly against it in defense of our
country and our constitution our freedom
i would like to see a cognitive test
i get asked a lot of questions about you
because you are not part of this radical
democratic party but you still consider
yourself a democrat
one do you ever imagine
becoming a republican you ran for
president once would you run for
president as an independent a lot of
people ask about think that that might
be your final goal
neither of those things are things that
i'm giving any thought to
i am very focused on doing all that i
can as many americans are across the
country in recognizing the crisis of
this moment the challenges that we face
that we've just talked about here and
how critical it is that whether we're a
democrat an independent or a republican
that we stand together and fight for our
freedom to support and uphold and defend
our constitution and bill of rights this
is at the core of who we are as a
country and our democracy is under
attack from our leaders right here at
home this is critical for us to stand
together and to stay focused on
protecting and defending it
tulsi gabbard thank you as always hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else